who has made you laugh the most in
between takes my husband Ben Jennifer
Lopez answers vogue's 73 questions and
drop some sweet references to her man
Ben Affleck we're super happy what can I
tell you we're just having a good time
and get this she wants to make a sequel
to one of the biggest box office bombs
of her career and Ben's why don't we try
and make this Pleasant
okay
nice
the triple threat welcomes the mag into
her home and talks all things work
motherhood and love and what advice
would you give about love today
and it starts with you
and when asked which of her movies she'd
like to revisit she says she's ready for
Julie 2.0
and which of your movies would you most
want to make a sequel of
Julie critically acclaimed I think it's
a really sweet movie I think people are
going to enjoy it there's some really
funny stuff in it yeah let's be honest
the 2003 movie was widely panned by fans
and critics and it only made 7 million
at the box office on a 75 million dollar
budget it was worth it but it makes
sense Jayla would pick the flick since
she and Ben started dating on the set of
the romantic comedy in 2002.
I'm sorry do we know each other not yet
it's an added bonus to find somebody you
know that was such a good friend that
when the movie was over I thought to
myself this person will be my friend you
know and you don't find that every day
either so uh it's a very special thing
for both of us flash forward to this
summer and the couple tied the knot
nearly two decades after calling off
their first engagement in 2004. it was
my first kind of heartbreak we were
about to get married it didn't work out
and it was just a bad heartbreak it was
like
a tough one for me and earlier this year
Ben admitted he had no regrets about
making the maligned movie either during
a chat with his buddy Matt Damon I did
get to meet Jennifer who
um the the relationship with whom has
been uh really meaningful to me my life
but back to Jen oh God
last week the singer announced she's
dropping a new album next year this is
me now on the 20th anniversary of this
is me then
this is me now
this is me now
what's your favorite song from that
album
dear Ben yeah the OG album was inspired
by her and Ben's first shot at Romance
[Music]
so it's no surprise her new record also
inspired by Ben the same way this is me
then captured a moment in time a very
special moment in time
this album
also did the same thing so this is me
now a newlywed with a new album on the
way
I have everything I want
[Music]